oral la parole est à madame thuan bora
pour le groupe l'est républicain pour
cinq minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
culture monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues ces derniers mois plusieurs
big bang annoncées par le gouvernement
se sont transformés en mesure est sur
l'audiovisuel ce sont les aléas
epidemics et calendaires qui ont eu
raison du projet doit structurelles que
notre assemblée aurait dû examiner à
défaut c'est un texte allait pur plus
limitée que vous nous avez présenté
pourtant là coville n'a pas eu raison du
piratage et n'a pas fait disparaître les
attentes d'un secteur audiovisuel
constitutif de notre patrimoine commun
à rebours de ce qui se fait
habituellement à cette tribune je tiens
à souligner ce que ce projet de loi ne
dit pas ne crée pas et ne prévoit pas en
débit en dépit pardon des
bouleversements induits par la société
de l'écran les enjeux du numérique
impliquent en effet de faire évoluer un
cadre législatif et romatif par trop
dépassé nous pensons aux lois de 86 et
2009 mais également aux instruments qui
assure actuellement la régulation d'une
grande nation culturelle doit à ses
créateurs
cette déception sur le cadre restreint
de la loi se double d'une inquiétude
légitime car les crédits de l'art comme
dépendront d'un budget dont nous ne
savons rien et qui cette année revêtira
de caractéristiques particulières il
s'agira de la dernière loi de finances
de ce quinquennat et celle ci s'inscrira
dans un contexte de crise dont nous
savons la rudesse pour le monde culturel
j'insisterai sur trois éléments du
projet de loi originel que notre
rapporteur et plusieurs de mes collègues
ont eu à coeur de gommer
le texte initial ne traitait pas hélas
des disparités réglementaire qui obère
les capacités d'investissement des
acteurs historiques je pense au
dispositif anti-concentration
mentionnées à l'article 41 de la loi
léotard dont le csh times estime lui
même qu'il est obsolète face aux
évolutions démographiques fyk
économiques et technologiques du secteur
je pense aussi aux limites imposées au
groupe en matière du rachat des chaînes
de la tnt et au manque d'incitations à
l'intégration verticale
indispensable au financement programmes
de flux qui contribuent aussi au
dynamisme de la création française
le texte initial ne traitait pas non
plus hélas des difficultés d'un secteur
radiophonique en crise structurelle
alors que nous célébrons les 100 ans de
ce média et les 40 ans de la libération
de la bande fm nous aurions pu intégrer
nos discussions la question du régime
des mentions légales ou des quotas en
effet le développement des plateformes
de streaming audio qui échappent à cette
régulation devra nous conduire tôt ou
tard à répondre à un dilemme
fondamentale et tendre ses quotas au
service de musique à la demande ou
réviser les trois régimes existants nous
savons que l'enchevêtrement des critères
bri parfois la liberté éditoriale des
professionnels
le texte initial ne traitait pas non
plus hélas de la modernisation d'une tnt
que nous savons économique écologique et
surtout vectrices d'un maillage
territorial
indispensable à l'égalité devant l'offre
audiovisuelle
en somme nous débattons donc
principalement d'une loi antipiratage
dont la mesure phare demeure la création
de l'art comme et sur ce point aussi
pourquoi ne pas être allé plus loin
madame la ministre en vous inspirant du
modèle britannique et de leurs
puissantes office des communications je
rappelle que chez nos voisins qui ont eu
plus de dix ans d'avancé sur la
directive et sema ce sont cinq entités
fusionnées des capacités d'en quête qui
garantissent l'effectivité des missions
de cette super autorité de contrôle
madame la ministre c'est avec la scène
exigence qui caractérise cette assemblée
son esprit d'ouverture et sa technicité
que nous saluons les intuitions d'un
texte dont le cadre nous apparaît
toutefois trop restreint
permettez moi de citer l'un de vos
illustres prédécesseurs pour vous dire
notre bienveillant déception et l'esprit
constructif qui nous dit sous
l'impulsion du rapporteur hugonnet ainsi
que l'écrivait maurice druon la critique
nous est profitable
quand elle nous aide à travailler dans
le sens de l'amélioration
merci chers collègues dans la suite de
la discussion la parole est à michel
savin pour le groupe l'est républicain
pour 4 minutes
[Applaudissements]